this year's military ruler has proposed
a three-year transition of power after
West African leaders made another
attempted diplomacy to reverse the coup
the statement by General abduramani
chiani followed talks with a delegation
from West Africa's main Regional block
ecowas they also met niger's deposed
president it's the first time Muhammad
bazoom has been seen in public since
last month's military takeover Nicholas
hark reports
answering the junta's call to mobilize
tens of thousands of volunteers gathered
outside of niger's National Stadium to
join the armed forces for Vegeta this is
a show of popular support for last
month's coup an act of defiance in the
face of the threat of military action
from the West African body ecowas which
wants to reinstate the deposed elected
president bazoom and the crew leader
General chiani delivered a message of
his own after meeting an ecowas
delegation in the capital Miami
neither the National Council for the
Safeguard of the Homeland nor the people
of Niger want war and remain open to
dialogue but let us be clear if an
attack were to be undertaken against us
it will not be the walk in the park some
people seem to think
delegation also met with president
bazoom he's being held with little
access to food or electricity his health
is reportedly deteriorating
we met him we heard from him what was
done to him he told us about the
problems he's facing that we will take
to the leaders that sent us here
the Junta accused him of treason for
acting in the interest of a foreign
State alluding to France the former
colonial power
the wilt Act militarily is to stop what
could be seen as a contagion of coups
there's been coups in Guinea Burkina
Faso and Mali countries who carry the
ecowas Mandate like Senegal and Ivory
Coast want to stop this but these states
are seen as too close to France the
former colonial power for part of the
population ecowas is seen as the armed
branch of the former colonial power
the Gentile leaders in neighboring Mali
and Burkina Faso have sent their
military planes in solidarity to niger's
coup leader General chiani and his
supporters seem to be determined to
cling on to power no matter the
consequences
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
meanwhile Washington which has a strong
military presence in Niger has sent its
new ambassador to the capital Naomi Mr
Williams served as the U.S ambassador to
Niger she explains why the military
leadership hasn't managed to fully
control the country
this Hunter is throwing up everything it
can possibly hear about because it's
obviously not thinking very well but um
and seeing if it will work uh they have
professed to want uh to have free
Freedom of Choice yet they have
repressed any of the pro-basum
demonstrations and my understanding is
that there have been demonstrations all
over the country or attempted
demonstrations they have the guns uh we
I also have heard lots of reports about
uh discontent within the military
um and you are seeing a lot of
vulnerability in Niger right now since
so many of the Armed Forces have been
pulled into where neone is and away from
uh the outskirts of the other regions of
the of the country leaving It Wide Open
um so there's disorientation there's
confusion and there I understand there's
a lot of Discord in the ranks